how does it feel to be so great but
you're number two are you asking me
because I lost a Quest Crew twice oh no
what I wasn't even thinking what the
[ __ ]
[Music]
you know I'm usually not into the
celebrity gossip and love Live Celebrity
Goss oh come on Gossip is awesome yeah
all I'm saying what's your gosh Joe what
do you like I like when I found out that
um people like to eat hamburgers more
than Ramen
that's celebrity romance gossip that did
change my life that changed my
perspective hold on where did you read
that on the food Inc and were you just
like what the [ __ ] I couldn't believe
this
Burgers over burgers versus Ramen Joe
was that you I was the writer yeah I was
all right
it's a one person sample it's a personal
realization
okay and you know what he's like I'm a
celebrity I get it yeah yeah a little
biased but you know okay okay well this
one this one's just funny can we go back
to this one I can't dude I can't order
okay basically
um
Scottie Pippen's ex-wife Larson Pippen
and Michael Jordan's son Marcus Jordan
get the [ __ ] out of here are you [ __ ]
kidding me is that what the [ __ ] are you
talking about
that's like basketball royalty roll
ex-wife Michael Jordan's kid Marcus
Jordan yeah
are all together yeah wait Scotty
Pippen's ex-wife's kid dude the Pippins
were just born to be number two huh
they're just born to Jordan like just
always Pippins is like no matter what
like do are taking it doggy what do they
look like together yeah is it like Jada
Pinkett Smith with like
future with a young man yeah I mean no I
mean Larson pimping you know she's she's
no she's fired
no but it just sounds like someone
that's older with someone that's really
young because Scottie Pippen is much
older yeah but he he married a younger
one yeah he likes him oh that makes
sense now okay I was thinking like his
first one I gotta say it like that no I
just that's what he said on record yeah
he said he said he goes I'm Scotty
Pippen and I like him yeah no I was
picturing like his first wife is that a
campaign
his interview it was on the last dance
so uh just to give everybody the age
Larsa Pippin who was married to Scotty
for 23 years wow good number almost
so she's in her 40s then yeah
and they have four kids together she is
now 48 years old dude she got four kids
with them that's four kids and uh uh
Marcus Jordan is 31. oh okay so they
meet 17 years ago had a basketball game
kids her kids friends oh dude because
aren't like Scottie Pippen and Michael
are they like cool now I don't remember
they're cool but like they're not like
they're Business Schools no like they're
cool like they're cool but like Scotty
just has some memories and then Jordan
has some memories there's some
resentment there's some friction between
both parts because it's like Jordan and
I'm just quoting the Last Dance I don't
[ __ ] know guys it's just amazing it
was amazing but Jordan remembers Scotty
quitting on the team right that's right
that's right and then uh Scotty's like
hey I did it for myself because I was
finally gonna get paid for once Michael
you're gonna [ __ ] getting paid off
the ass the whole time [ __ ] money
coming out of your [ __ ] balls like
the whole time is that quote Yeah so
that's what that's he was jealous you
think Scotty was jealous of Jordan just
a little I don't think so dude so
Michael Jordan was petty about it and
then when he had his kid he whispered
he's like yeah
you said every day until the kid was
like 30 [ __ ] three every day in the
news he planted that
you know with Jordan now not playing
right do you think his competitiveness
came now into his shoes like is he is he
involved in that because like I'm I'm
joined competitive competitiveness is
like always the game was just that in
that time but so what's what's it now
everything golf right now golf is huge
for him Jordan dominated the whole thing
like like Jordan owns shoes and and
Pippin is a [ __ ] Hobbit who doesn't
even wear shoes
no but Pippin is that [ __ ] guy from
Lord of the Rings he doesn't even wear
shoes oh I see yeah he's definitely
he'll never be the Frodo what's his name
now Pippin was the friend oh pip yeah
Mary and Pippin yeah yeah I'm telling
you he doesn't wear shoes because
Scotty was so vindictive he's like if
you want to use my name he's like you
better not let him wear [ __ ] shoes
how does it feel to be so great but
you're number two or like number three
you know what I I feel bad for people
like just to get into basketball talk I
feel bad for you asking me because I
lost a quest through twice oh no what I
wasn't even thinking what the [ __ ] is
that why you asked over here I didn't
know is that all right Ryan did you just
accept that because that's what you're
thinking I thought you were actually
[ __ ] I'm just speaking to The Ether
but now we're on the topic what the hell
let's do it no I was gonna say just
speaking from basketball like I would
hate to be people like Carl Malone you
know I mean people who had to play oh
yeah yeah it was [ __ ] good had all
these stats and never got a chance to
get a ring like that's yeah that's
pretty tough yo Charles yeah Charles
that's that's to me
way more tough because that's the only
Legacy that you get to walk away with at
the end of it there's all these fools
off the benches that didn't do [ __ ] and
he's [ __ ] like PT guys and stuff that
all have these giant championship rings
for doing nothing yeah or guys I got
traded mid-season [ __ ] benched the
entire time win Rings yeah and then you
got these other guys who have like high
scoring or assist records of all time
never got a chance to get a ring that
that's just crazy to me so does that
mean [ __ ] the ring because it means
nothing the ring is everything at the
end of the day you know what I mean when
you when you [ __ ] are are gonna die
later and you gotta pass something on
it's like you have a ring you don't
leave it in your casket with you and
you'll die like this no you'll get grave
robbed two years ago two years ago
everyone said no question it's Michael
or it's LeBron and now Curry all of a
sudden is in that conversation because
of the Rings it's all the Rings baby
it's all the rooms Lord of the Rings
Curry is definitely in the conversation
oh dude he is he's deaf he changes the
game the only reason I want to get more
into sports so I could gamble with you
guys more no easier when you don't know
yeah yeah yeah Joe we need you to be we
need you to be our fish
so like just to play speculative for
absolutely no reason other than gossip
what do you guys think Scottie Pippen's
feeling right about it
that my boys hurt I'd be hurt that's
your baby mama I think he's feeling like
he always feels I think he's feeling
like a number two but by this time
though if you already had a divorce
aren't you just like good riddance yeah
baby yeah but do you think he like locks
it on everywhere and like sees like
Jordan's shoes and just [ __ ] hates
being reminded it's like Jordan's
[ __ ] my ex-wife right now you know
what's funny is like out of all the
people
they hang out with some crazy circles
for sure because they're all like
ex-ball players they're all very famous
and [ __ ] out of all the people she
[ __ ] gets a relationship with like
she could probably have so many [ __ ]
dudes that is what David's saying
whatever the [ __ ] [ __ ] Luke Longley dude
maybe that's why oh [ __ ] she should you
know and then she stumbles upon Michael
Jordan's son have some respect or Robert
or Robert parish's great grandson
her options are limited because of her
circle of friends
because all of her like lives is like
Basketball Wives and basketball I didn't
even know [ __ ] Michael Jordan had a
son until this she's a basketball
ex-wife so I wonder what that circle's
like I think at the end of the day like
imagine Scottie Pippen now right nobody
doesn't not know who Scottie Pippen is
still basically if I saw Scottie Pippen
right you'd be like oh dude you could
recognize him like so easy yeah I didn't
think about all the [ __ ] that might
be running into him Jordan's such
[ __ ] your ex what like you know what
I mean like I could just only imagine
how [ __ ] up people are because when
you hear news like this or gossip like
this
man it's interestingness
I put this in your head real quick look
around the room if you are Michael
Jordan and your son is Marcus Jordan
what do you [ __ ] say stop [ __ ] her
oh is that really maybe I just did it I
don't know you know what I mean you
think that's what it is though that's
cold I think he's like I don't think
Michael Jordan's like you shouldn't have
done that do you think he's so
competitive that he's like Scotty should
have done something about it then no he
he would be like why'd you just [ __ ]
Cheryl swoops this kid
any chance you get what about deadlift
shrimps kid dude hey I don't Sully that
name do you think he's competitive in
that way though do I think he's
competitive in everything yeah Michael
Jordan is competitive the director of
The Last Dance one of my favorite things
that he said about interviewing Michael
was he's like we got into Michael's car
and he's like we're headed towards you
know um
an arena to watch a basketball game and
Jordan wanted to do a bet with me in the
car about how many Air Jordans I would
see like from people as we're headed to
that stadium and what was the over under
and Jordan but the over and I bet the
under and I lost and Jordan like was
getting off on it
dude that's pretty it's also a gambling
addict what happens when he loses though
he pays up because he has all the money
he makes the next bag pissed dude he
probably wants it says double or nothing
and some other thing comes up yeah and
then he wins he wins yeah until he wins
because he has the [ __ ] money to do
it do you think it's exhausting to
handle Michael Jordan all day yeah only
unless you're okay constantly being
number two unless you got a bigger Bank
that's true and then you get
you get if you're very competitive
that's probably really fun which was why
he was hanging out with tiger wasn't
[ __ ] when he [ __ ] basically that's a
great example [ __ ] bananas you know
what I mean that's a great example you
you play a sport better than him like
that like and he has a passion for that
sport that's good and if you were to
like gamble against tiger in Golf Tiger
who whip his ass so he's probably like I
[ __ ] with you you're a goat in your
lane you know what I mean yeah even in
the original Space Jam Larry Bird and
them looked annoyed hanging out with him
why are you gonna say the original Space
Jam yeah the real one just like there's
only one nobody except Space Jams well
because it's important to say Space Jam
2 sucks yeah nobody likes it what did
you guys expect did even like an infant
enjoy it or like
like was it dazzling enough to the
senses was there enough colors bouncing
around for an infant even like like I
don't think anyone enjoyed it bro there
was a lot of colors not enough maybe too
many yeah bro this is probably the best
story I think
I've heard in a long time
this is so vindictive and crazy that's
crazy I can't believe it's actually
happening I honestly read I was like
whoa I looked around I was like nobody's
here I can't wait to tell Steve no legit
this is so goddamn good that's good
gossip good job hey hey it is truly is
always the kind of Gossip we like
Pizza
thank you